il ya un film qui parle de la police
dans des termes qu'on a relativement peu
l'habitude d'entendre
je dirais pas que c'est une révolution
galiléennes dans le cinéma ce serait
absolument délirant mais il ya quelque
chose dans l 627 qui s'attache à casser
les vieux systèmes de représentations
sur la police alors je vais pas très
longuement ou trop longuement parlé du
film disons en deux mots que on suit un
policier qui est interprété par par
didier bezace on le suit dans le
quotidien dans le quotidien de son
boulot dans le quotidien de ses bureaux
dans le quotidien de ces enquêtes avec
ses indics avec ses collègues avec ses
supérieurs hiérarchiques et que le
constat que taverny en tire est un
constat accablant accablants sur l'état
de la police en france dans la partie
documentaire est à table en aussi sur
finalement l'hypocrisie de chacun
d'entre nous qui préféreront peut-être
détourner les yeux de cette réalité
dérangeante parce que s'il y avait
vraiment un adjectif à donner au film de
tavernier c'est vraiment qu'il est
dérangeant est-ce que les réactions de
paul quilès qui vous a accusé de
présenter une vision caricaturale de la
réalité vous conforte dans ce
dérangement que vous vouliez cause et
bertrand tavernier
oui elle m'attriste ont aussi parce que
je pensais pas que
qui l'aurait la stupidité de faire ça et
en même temps de nous il devient attaché
de presse quoi c'est formidable ça lui
ce sera un métier où pourra se recycler
du coup c'est les boules qui laisse ça
il pas ici fort mais quand même
pourquoi s'en priver sait on en revient
sur lui en revenir à galilée c'est segal
il est qui qui demande aux notables de
regarder par le son télescope les gens
et les gens qui disent non on va
demander un rapport à la salle à
l'astronome du du pape qui nous prouvera
que ce que vous voyez vous ne pouvez pas
le voir c'est un petit peu ce qui est ce
qui est en train d'arriver je trouve ça
un peu triste je pensais un peu triste
et besoins vous avez comme comment vous
vous être apportées à ce rôle là vous
avez enquêté vous même vous avez écouté
des policiers vous avez un oranger
j'ai plongé dans le scénario dans le
tournage et puis j'ai j'ai fait les
gestes qu'il me suis attaché
et bertrand il tenait beaucoup pour nous
tous d'ailleurs pour moi comme pour les
comédiens qui interprètent les six
policiers de la brigade à une pratique à
une pratique du métier qui nous menait
dans nos actions
et c'est ça qui nous a qui nous a guidés
bon en dehors de ça personnage que
j'interprète je dirais que c'est un
certain type fatigué mais têtue fatigue
et entêté comme on doit l'être un peu
tous en ce moment peut-être en france
parce que je crois que le film il est
sur la police mais il est il est serein
et sûr un état dans lequel sur un état
dans lequel on est tous deux à la fois
de d'indignations de rage et de
lassitude
voilà l'article l 627 c'est l'article
code qui réprime les infractions sur la
drogue et tout le film se passe dans
cette sorte de de poursuite inlassable
de deux flics et de dealer avec
l'impression que c'est à la fois un
combat absolument interminable que la
hiérarchie s'en fout que finalement
qu'est ce qui les motive enfin qu'est ce
qui fait que dès que des policiers
continuent finalement avoir cette sorte
d'énergie à traquer des divers qui vont
retrouver le lendemain le surlendemain
je crois que ce qu'il est ce qu'ils
m'ont fait pas ce métier
enfin on peut le faire pour bien bien
des raisons mais en l'occurrence le
personnage que je joue il aime ce métier
il aime ce métier donc il est
constamment entre la rage des mille
métiers de ne pas pouvoir bien le faire
et puis et puis là l'espèce de
résistance très grande
ils ont tous parce que ce sont des gens
tenaces et qui retourne qui retourne au
labeur sont des gens de labeur et moi je
crois que le film touchera les
spectateurs parce que à travers à
travers ce métier là ces gens qui font
de ce boulot qui sont un peu mythique
dans nos têtes
il ya des hommes ordinaires des femmes
ordinaires qui travaillent et
ils ont besoin ces gens là que leur
travail ne soient pas dévaluer que ça
ressemble à que ça ressemble à quelque
chose que c'est un sens que ça se fasse
pas pour rien dans des conditions
absurdes et inutilement voilà c'est ça
et tout le monde a besoin de ça il ya un
regard très très dur et très ironique
quoi sur les locaux absolument pour
graver dans lesquelles les flics font
leur boulot et puis à côté il ya bureau
absolument magnifique avec des dés de la
verdure d'aidé du des comme on appelle
ça des trucs des structures paysagères
etc oui et ça c'est la prospection pour
le devenir de la délinquance dans l'em2
et ça c'est vrai ça c'est vrai ça c'est
vrai et avec des communautés déjà des
paysages floraux qui était à peu près un
million chacun mais qui arrivait et est
imaginaire
le seul truc que j'avais en quatre mois
dans le groupe setec j'avais une
mobylette mais ce parti pris ce parti
pris de réalisme là vous lui donnez quoi
vous lui donner une fonction politique
aujourd'hui ou esthétique temps c'est
pas un film réaliste je trouve enfin moi
moi je suis souvent depuis que le film
ait vu je suis super fois gêné par par
ce rapport comme ça documentaire como
mais ça c'est pas un film réalisé par
exemple la manière dont on l'a c'est un
film épique avec la manière dont on
redécouvre
la ville paris la manière dont le temps
et télescoper tout temps tout le temps
n'est pas de l'ordre de la du réalisme
effectivement ce qui est le réalise un
renvoi au vrai c'est à dire au fait que
ces gens travaillent dans des locaux
très exigu sont dans des lieux pour y
est vive
un temps qui est tout entier qui est
tout le temps télescoper parce qu'il
faut courir à droite à gauche et c est
quoi ça on n'est jamais bien sur ses
deux pieds c'est vrai que le tournage de
ressembler à ça on aimait ça nous a
aidés enfin moi comme acteur ça m'a aidé
[Musique]